yeah how long did you struggle when you
started to get these commercials you cut
it just catapulted right it was like a
domino effect so so you started getting
these but did you start to think
i want to act i'm doing commercials but
now i want to go to the next step i mean
next stage and did you have that agent
who can get you to those auditions or
were you just dealing mostly with
commercial agents
yeah i didn't have a theatrical agent i
just had commercial agents and
you know
it it was going good until it wasn't
meaning i was looking at
i was going into the agency off like the
agency to pick up like checks because i
was getting a lot of them because i was
doing a lot of commercials and i was
like man this is this is crazy right how
come i'm on i remember going into my
agent's office one time and they had
theatrical agents there
at it was called their first talent
group
and i pretty much was like the head of
their commercial division
you know but i couldn't get a meeting
with the theatrical agent to save my
life jesus
i'll go in there one time this guy goes
he goes hey man
dude you're all over my tv man
you were just playing on our tv here man
and i was like
okay
well sign me then let's roll you
what's wrong i'm clearly doing something
right he's like yeah man we're gonna
take a look man you know we're gonna
we're gonna take a look man you know how
it is man i don't
don't know how it is
tell me how it is
yeah and so didn't couldn't get a
meeting with those guys and then i
noticed that my check started slowing up
like i was like man
i'm still working my courses are airing
like a lot
like you can turn on tv i'm like three
spots in one commercial break and
i was like what's going on they're like
oh something's wrong with the mailing
system and it's this and it's that and
then mysteriously they found a bunch of
checks of mine just kind of sitting in a
drawer somewhere they're like oh there
you go how much money were in those all
those checks it was like fifty thousand
dollars was your sex i thought it was
like a box
like a stack i was like what
i was like
you just found them like what would have
happened if i would have said anything
then i then i go then they go under they
go out of business
and i re and i find that they have
they have taken me for over a hundred
grand
wow and they were robbing a lot of the
actors
and that's when i started getting checks
signed over to myself but not to the
agent
yeah it was it was uh i still haven't
resolved that it was bad holy
so i left that agency i will i would
hope you'd leave that agency
you